give that to your Saddler he'll provide
the rest you must shape the horse to the
rider start with a yearling teacher to
respond to the reins and to the boy's
voice I really be able to write you will
on horseback you'll be as tall as any of
them this is some kind of trick why do
you want to help him I pretend to
support my heart cripples bastards and
broken things what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another game
of thrones season 8 prediction video I
will be announcing the new winner of my
Game of Thrones Season 7 blu-ray
giveaway at the end of those videos so
make sure you stay until the end to see
if you've won but let's get into today's
topic there are several characters I
need to talk about so I want to get
started right away about 9 months ago
before season 7 aired I made a video
about which characters I thought would
be responsible for winning the great war
and ending the long night so far my
prediction seems to be coming true but
now that season 7 is over I wanted to
update this video before the final
season airs in the first season in this
series there was an episode called
cripples bastards and broken things and
I believe that these characters featured
in this episode would end up being some
of the most important characters in this
entire story each of these characters
will play a role in defeating the night
king and his massive army in order to
even stand a chance against the night
king everyone will need to provide some
type of service even from some of the
unlikeliest of characters which are the
cripples bastards and broken things you
can see that all of the characters who
were heavily featured in this episode
have already made it until the final
season there will be a bittersweet
ending though so some of these
characters may die some of them probably
will die but not before they put up one
hell of a fight when you think about it
most of the characters from this episode
should be dead already
Jon Snow was stabbed multiple times
including a fatal blow delivered right
through his heart
but the power from the Lord of Light
brought him back he even managed to
survive a dangerous mission beyond the
wall when it looked like all hope was
lost
daenerys targaryen spent most of her
life running from the usurpers hired
knives and she was even moments away
from ingesting poison not to mention she
has survived multiple fires that would
have killed anyone else Arya Stark was
also stabbed several times that would
have killed any other character that
isn't wearing Valyrian steel plot armor
brain stark should have died when he
fell from the broken Tower and he should
have died before he even reached the
three-eyed Ravens cave or at the very
least he should have died when the
knight king attacked the three-eyed
Ravens cave but he is still here Tyrion
Lannister should have died during the
Battle of Blackwater Bay and Tyrion
should have died after Oberyn Martell
lost a trial by combat but he escaped
death once again Samwell Tarly has come
face-to-face with a white Walker twice
but he has managed to survive ginjury
should have died when all of King
Robert's other bastards were being
killed at an alarming rate
Gendry should have also died while he
was being held captive on Dragonstone by
Stannis and Melisandre Jorah Mormont
should have been beheaded by Ned Stark
and he definitely should have died when
he contracted greyscale but here he
stands the Hound should be dead right
now
Brienne beat the breaks off the hound
and Arya left him for dead but the Lord
of Light isn't finished with him either
even Theon Greyjoy should be dead right
now he was tragically mutilated but he
should have never made it out of
Ramsay's grasp alive and last but not
least Jaime Lannister is another
character who should have died on
multiple occasions especially during
season seven when he came face-to-face
with drogue on but here he is even with
one hand he is ready to help defeat the
night king all of these characters
should be dead right now
but they aren't they were all kept alive
for a very specific reason these
characters will survive until the very
end and each one of them will provide a
service that will be needed in order to
end a long night some of the biggest
badasses and greatest warriors this
story has ever given us are already dead
people like Barristan Selmy called Drogo
Oberyn Martell one one and many more
those are all characters I thought would
have been perfect against the night King
but even they couldn't survive so you
have to ask yourself why are all of
these cripples bastards and broken
things still
around some of the characters featured
in this episode seemed so unlikely to
make it this far but somehow they have
of course we all know how important
brain Stark is now but when this series
began who would have thought this
crippled little boy would have become so
important he is arguably going to be
needed the most in order to stop the
night king without him they may not have
been able to do it even Jon Snow when we
first meet him it wasn't likely he would
end up where he is right now it took for
some very extreme circumstances to
happen for Jon Snow to be in the current
position he is in he was a bastard boy
in the Nights Watch and he should have
been living out the rest of his days at
Castle black but now he is the king in
the north preparing to lead the fight
against the darkness coming to lay over
the world when we first meet Samwell
Tarly he is one of the most pathetic men
to ever join the Nights Watch
he couldn't even hold a sword let alone
fight and he was scared of heights
even though he knew he would eventually
have demand the top of the wall it was
pretty sad and even John felt bad for
him but it didn't take long for this
broken man to rise in this world and
become the key figure in learning how to
defeat the White Walkers
Sam's role wasn't finished just yet and
he still holds some important
information that is yet to be revealed
but I believe he will find it in some of
those books or documents he took from
the Citadel with Sam's help they will
find a way to survive the greatest
threat the realm has ever known Arya
Stark was just as little girl who wanted
to learn how to water dance and protect
herself but now she has become this
badass ninja assassin who holds one of
the few Valyrian steel weapons that will
be used to take down some of the White
Walkers her skill set should be very
useful in the war to come and I can't
forget about Tyrion the IMP Lannister it
seemed like this man was destined to end
up like Robert Baratheon just drinking
and whoring his way through life but
look at him now he ran into some bumps
along the road during season 7 but he
did earn his hand to the Queen title
unlike when he was hand to the king
during his father's absence although he
did prove he could handle the job when
need be he also earned his stripes
during the Battle of Blackwater Bay
and I think Tyrians advising and war
tactics should be vital during the war
against the night king ginjury was also
just another bass
that seemed like he would be a
dime-a-dozen blacksmith for the rest of
his life or roaming the woods with the
Brotherhood without banners but after he
disappeared for multiple seasons he
found his way back into the main plot
ginjury was brought back for a reason
and it must have something to do with
his skills as a blacksmith or bringing
together houses Stark and Baratheon
after the war is over
Gendry will be needed to ensure that
house Baratheon does not go extinct and
before it's all said and done he could
end up in a very powerful position now
that the Hound is back he has seen the
light and his services are gonna be used
for something good the Hound is gonna be
a strong soldier for this war and I
can't wait to see him kick some white
Walker ass hopefully he does get his
hands on some Valyrian steel something
he said he has always wanted but
regardless if he does or not the
Brotherhood without banners were right
the Lord of Light isn't done with the
hounds just yet and his role is just
getting started
I loved watching this episode again now
knowing with hindsight just how
important these cripples bastards and
broken things really are at first glance
most of these characters were being
overlooked and I love underdog stories I
love seeing characters rise to greatness
that once had no business of being in
any position to do so but I am going to
assume Dan and Dave will keep the
essence of George RR Martin's story and
give this a bittersweet ending so we
could see some significant losses before
it's all said and done one of the most
popular phrases in this story as all men
must die so even though these characters
will play their important roles it
doesn't necessarily mean they will
survive the winter
but these cripples bastards and broken
things will all leave their marks on
this world they will end up being more
important to the survival of the realm
than all of the other kings queens lords
and ladies who look down on them for
most of their lives and who knows maybe
the theory about Sam being the narrator
of this story is true and if it is true
and we do see Sam as an old man reading
or writing down the final pages of this
moment in time then I am confident he
will give these characters their proper
time to shine on the pages knowing they
stepped up in the most dire of
situations to do what they could to save
the realm in possibly even sacrificing
themselves to ensure that others would
survive
that could be a better sweet ending in
itself or at least it would be for me
but of course we are going to need
several armies in several large dragons
to fight the night king but without the
prep work done by characters like John
bran Sam and even Tyrion none of that
other stuff would even matter but these
are just my opinions of course and you
can certainly disagree so comment down
below and let me know what you think
about this do you agree with me or do
you see it playing out another way
before I go when I announce the new
winner of the Game of Thrones Season 7
giveaway the winner of today's blu-ray
is our Blankenship congratulations make
sure you contact me and confirm that
this is you just send me an email or
private message me on youtube and I will
send your copy right away I want to
thank everyone for entering and everyone
who took the time to watch this video I
really do appreciate that I do have one
more giveaway to do for Christmas just
to thank all of you for continuing to
support the channel so make sure you
watch my next video to find out the
details about that one it's gonna be a
big one that I think you will love but
have a great day everyone
I will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]